llega
Thank you.
I'm sorry.
there's going to be
So let's talk.
And in the other one.
And what that means.
I'm sorry.
Yeah.
But yeah.
I'm sorry.
But once you're sorry.
So right.
I'm sorry.
So we're sorry.
All right.
I'm sorry.
We're sorry.
There's an enemy.
I'm sorry.
All right.
And this is really cool.
plays into these plays.
Those new skill points.
I'm sorry.
And this is a lot.
on the one.
So you see, it's a lot.
It looks so sweet.
And there's a lot.
We've got, you know, we've got, you know,
bear with us.
We're going to get to lead the
and we're going to do, you know,
and we're going to do, you know, you can find some, you can find some, you know, you can find some, you know,
and so on the sagte, you can find someunt Madison.
down enemies as well all right so that is a druid really looking forward to playing some druid uh
in 2.0 but let's move on to the necromancer because we've got a lot to get through
uh we've got soul rift this is a new darkness ultimate skill so necromancers kind of had three
ultimates already they had one that was blood one that was bone and one that was related to summoning
and now we've kind of completed it and we've added a darkness or shadow damage ultimate
soul rift creates an area around your character kind of follows with you that just constantly
deals damage over time and it's going to be sucking out the souls of enemies who you're hitting
and every time it sucks out a soul from an enemy you're going to gain some essence and you're going
to gain a barrier so you can stack up this barrier it helps you be survivable um and it deals you know
really good damage over time supreme soul rift gives you bonus damage for every soul that you absorb
and prime soul rift causes the soul absorption to also apply vulnerable let's take a video of this
in action here right so enemies are all coming up super useful charles right now that like you have
another way to give yourself defenses uh necro has historically had some trouble with that right
yeah absolutely uh i think that's a really important part here um and when we get to the
the next slide talk about some of the passives we'll i'll highlight we're adding a bit more
barrier into the necromancer's kit um you know blood necromancers always had a really easy time
surviving they had a lot of fortify and a lot of max health um and really they the other ones like
the bone and shadow uh necro didn't have quite as much survivability and so now we're introducing
more barrier in more places to ensure that that kind of non-blood necromancer builds the shadow and
the bone and summon necros um have a bit more survivability and are able to scale into that late game
pretty well all right so as i mentioned the new passive so they have a new key passive called
affliction that uh there's this new concept of affliction where um applying vulnerable crowd
control or shadow damage over time effects to enemies will apply them with affliction which is
going to make them take increased damage from you and your minions additionally when you apply a curse
skill to someone or to an enemy who has this affliction you're going to do a big chunk of
shadow damage so this kind of turns your your curse skills your decrepify and iron maiden into
offensive skills you can curse an area and then they take a big chunk of damage as well
um and this will scale up with the bonus damage that you've dealt uh or that you or the bonus affixes
that you have for that crowd control vulnerable and shadow damage and along that same theme the new
legendary paragon node frailty is going to cause cursed enemies to take more damage from you and
so it plays very nicely with the affliction key passive and uh once again more uh more skill tree
passives to spend those extra points on and i want to highlight necrotic fortitude here in the upper right
that gives you uh it's just a generic passive that gives you a chance a lucky hit chance to gain a
barrier and so that's going to be really good for anybody who wants just a bit more bump of
survivability and to play into the more barrier focused uh on necromancer uh yeah going back to
affliction really quick i love the idea of using my curses uh offensively like as a damage skill i think
that's going to be such a blast yeah yeah it's really cool to just yeah definitely gonna gonna be blasting
with them um i think it's really thematic too i love playing with it it pairs really well with the utility
changes now that we have way more size increases in utility gives you so many more utility options
those curses get pretty huge um and it feels great yeah yeah for all of us who just want to win by debuff
spamming i love that one absolutely all right let's talk about some of the new items coming for
necromancer here so we've got a new unique item the unmaker a unique helm this is going to empower the
soul rift the the new uh ultimate skill of course you gain some skill ranks to soul rift because now
ultimate skills have skill ranks and every 30 essence that you spend while soul rift is active
will increase its duration up to eight seconds so as long as you're active and kind of spending the
essence with the unmaker you're gonna have a very long duration of soul rift and then for every essence
that you gain while it's active which absorbing the souls does trigger essence gain you're going to do a
pulse of damage around you some bonus damage and so it really encourages you to just keep soul rift
up all the time be constantly gaining and spending the essence and it's going to be really really fun to
to make that build work additionally we've got reaping lotus aspect this empowers your sever your core
skill uh sever will no longer return to you previously sever was kind of an out and back situation now it
just goes out and then it splits into three specters at the end deals some extra bonus damage and then
that's the the end of the sever so it really does empower it on on the the swing out uh and looks
really cool uh we've got aspect of fell gluttony that empowers your golem whenever you cast your
golems active deals a big pulse of damage around it and your golem will then consume corpses to reduce
its cooldown so anybody who really wants to to build around making your golem as strong as possible this is
going to be the aspect for you and finally we've got phasing poltergeist's aspect which causes your bone
spirit to split into three spirits that deal a percentage of the damage as well i think we got
a video clip of this one because it looks really sweet uh so you cast bone spirit at one target and
then it spawns three little mini bone spirits to seek out nearby enemies as well so it kind of gives
you increased area of effect and if there's just one target of course it'll reconverge back on that same
target as well but also just adds a you know a bit more aoe capability for your bone spirit build
very cool all right so rogue rogue gets dance of knives this is a new channeled skill for rogue
it's an agility cutthroat skill and it also has a pretty interesting mechanic where it has some
charges that will recharge and the how long you can channel it is based on how many charges you have
it's going to take one charge per second of channeling but there's no energy cost or or just like
a normal cooldown uh here you can just channel it as long as you have charges and while you're
channeling you're gonna be spinning around you're gonna be throwing knives at enemies nearby and uh
you're against movement speed and dodge chance uh really is kind of like a spin to win kind of build
uh on rogue here uh you've got enhanced dance of knives which gives you some charge refund as you're
moving with it because that's what we really want to encourage is this constant motion this this forward
um momentum and uh methodical dance of knives drop some stun grenades when you finish channeling or
discipline dance of knives will slow enemies and has a chance to pierce through the enemies that
you're you're throwing the daggers at let's take a look at this in action so here we got the rogue
just going spinning throwing some daggers around at everyone and uh yeah this is awesome
speed farming like the best speed farming yeah and that animation is just amazing absolutely and you
can see there at the end they had the upgrade that drops a bunch of stun grenades at the end obviously
enemies were all dead but you know if you you use this to get into a big cluster of enemies then you
stop the channel you drop some stun grenades reset some of your charges and and you're good to start
spinning again ton of fun yeah those are perfect for like you run into an elite pack after slaughtering
a bunch of normals and it just annihilates the elites it feels amazing yeah all right so we've got
new passives as well uh new key passive is alchemical admixture and this is empowering your non-physical
damage so rogues can do poison shadow and cold through their various imbuements and when you deal three
different types of that non-physical damage the potency of your imbuement skills is going to be
dramatically increased for a time and the more bonus damage that you build on your gear for
bonus poison shot over cold damage the further that potency gets increased really encouraging
you to to mix and match the different elements it's really thematic with you know the alchemical kind of
theme and uh really uh supporting a build of rogue that we've kind of had in the game but really wanted
to give that robust support of a key passive for and also we've got a legendary paragon node the dance
macabre which encourages this kind of one-two combo of casting mobility or subterfuge skill increases
the damage of your next skill whatever it might be by quite a substantial amount so you can you know
cast your dash and then you know position yourself cast a big rain of arrows and it hits very hard
very cool and uh actually impacts your your moment to moment rotation as well
and of course we've got the new skill tree passes as well
all right new items we've got the pit fighters gall this is the ancestral unique ring or sorry just it's a
unique ring it's not necessarily you can find it before ancestral tier uh and this pit fighters gall
will empower your smoke grenade so your smoke grenade skill will deal in will increase your critical
strike damage and then leave a cloud of shadows behind and while you're within that cloud of
shadows you're going to be constantly regaining stealth and so there's a lot of interesting ways
you can play off of triggering going into or out of stealth and pit fighters gall is just going to
really enable that when you cast smoke grenade we've got aspect of star shards this is a new legendary
to directly support dance of knives and the daggers from dance of knives have a chance to shatter
dealing uh creating more shards of metal that deal bonus damage and you can now use combo points on
dance of knives to further increase the channel duration if you've opted into the combo points
specialization aspect of poisonous clouds plays well with pit fighters gall when you gain stealth you create a
cloud of poison damage and aspect of splendor shards uh there's just a chance whenever you're hitting a
frozen enemy to create some ice spikes so if you're freezing enemies because you're playing alchemical
admixture and using cold imbue splendor shards might be a good aspect for you as well
all right moving on to the sorceress the sorceress gets a new conjuration skill called the familiar
this is a conjuration skill that is all three elements it is a shock skill a pyromancy skill and
a frost skill so you there's three charges of it so you can cast it uh you know back to back and some
you summon a familiar of the element of your last skill cast so if you just cast a pyromancy skill
you're going to summon a fire familiar if you just cast a lightning skill you'll summon a lightning
familiar and same with a cold you'll summon a cold familiar and with the enhanced effect these familiars
will uh do a bonus effect so the fire familiar will constantly apply some burning to enemies that
it's around the cold familiar will chill and lightning familiar will stun and of course they'll their
damage type is going to be based on you know what type they are so that it'll benefit from all of your
you know bonus fire damage and that aura is really great right to tap into some of the keep or the
passives on the sorcerer yeah absolutely so you know if there's a lot of passive that say hey you
get bonuses uh against burning enemies for instance now if you have a fire familiar that's going to
really easily be able to apply that constantly and you're going to have pretty high uptime on having
familiars out because of the way the charge and duration works let's take a look at this in action
all right so initially we cast a frost familiar here right it it's jumping around and it's landing
it's doing frost damage then we cast a fire skill now we get a fire familiar jumping around and and
kind of dive bombing on enemies and then finally we get a shock familiar a lightning familiar here that's
going to be a lightning damage so you can kind of mix and match these uh depending on what skills you
use what combination you cast them in and uh it's really flexible it fits into a lot of different builds
you know even if you're just a pure say fire sword you just want to do fire damage you just want to do
burning this could still fit because you're just going to be able to summon the fire familiar but
it really reaches its maximum potential as you're you're kind of mix and matching these to to suit the
situation and and apply the the debuffs that you want onto the enemies you can have quite a few of
these out for the sega demonstration i think we we only have a couple of them out on screen but i think
you can have up to like six right yeah you can have up to six and uh that would make a lot more sense
once we get to uh talk about some of the the unique items uh that are coming with this patch
but first let's talk about the new passives and uh we've got enlightenment uh this really also plays
into the concept of mixing and matching the elements you see it's got all all three kind of colors on
there casting a skill grants a stack of enlightenment or three stacks if your skill was a different element
to the one before so you're alternating here and whenever you gain max stacks you're going
to become enlightened and you get a ton of bonuses for being in this enlightened state but then it
it drops off over time it's really a reward for mixing and matching those elements more so than any
other key passes we've had on srk before and similarly with the legendary paragon node fundamental release
each fire lightning cold attack you make in centimee increase the damage they take from all sources
uh by 10 so you really need to hit them with all three types to gain the maximum bonus here
all right on to the the unique items so uh siday bindings this is a unique gloves and this plays
right into the familiar so whenever you cast familiar with this unique on you're going to summon all three
elemental variants at once however it does come with a bit of restrictions on it so familiar's duration
is going to be dramatically increased and it's cooldown reduced but you're going to have one less charge of it
so you you won't be able to spam uh this quite as much but you know you press the button once or twice
and then you get the maximum familiar result they're all over the screen and they're going to last for
quite a long time with this with this unique love so it's going to be really really powerful too if you're
all about this conjuration build all about amping up the power from the familiar it's an awesome unique
for that additionally we've got new legendaries for the aspect of overheating after channeling incinerate
for a time you're going to deal bonus damage to the target and uh casting incinerate will uh refresh and
maintain the bonus so uh really just powering up your incinerate uh charged flash this empowers charged
bolts and after you hit a certain number of enemies with charged bolts your next three cast of charge
bolts will no longer send out bolts they're going to sound big waves of lightning that deal even more
damage and it's always going to be a crit and then aspect of elemental constellation once again uh more
about the the mixing and matching of all three elements uh casting a one of the elemental skills
will summon a matching type elemental dagger that'll pierce through enemies and uh if you the damage of
that dagger is going to be increased if you get all three of the different element types in that time frame
all right so i think uh oh right we've got myth new mythic uniques of course how can i forget new
mythic unique items these are the strongest items in the game uh we've got shroud of false death and i
think the really cool part about this is uh it's just inherent ethics it's going to grant plus one skill
rank to all passives and this is really awesome as we're adding new passives into the skill tree this
is just a ton of power for this this new unique uh chest and it's it's effect is what if you haven't
attacked in the last two seconds you're going to gain stealth and bonus movement speed now stealth
historically has just been a mechanic that has been on rogues and a little bit on druids with the werewolf
builds but now every class if you get this mythic unique is going to have some access to stealth you can
you know drop out of combat for a little bit and then you you get into self and you get tons
movement speed to you know maybe move on to the next pack or or move somewhere else in the dungeon
and it's a really simple line all passives but it's literally all passives which is insane like
it's incredibly powerful absolutely and we've also got the air of perdition a mythic unique helm
and this one has as an interesting effect so it's it says give into hatred and earn lilith's favor
increasing your damage dealt by 60 percent so just baseline this is a huge damage bonus
and the second line here says slaughtering enemies to briefly steal lilith's favor from
or slaughter enemies to briefly steal lilith's favor from nearby allies so this means if you're playing
in a group with uh you know somebody else who happens to have the air of perdition equipped you
are able to steal lilith's favor from them both will only favor one of you and you actually gain
double the bonus of this right if you you have if you steal someone else's favor you get 120 bonus
damage and and they would get zero uh but if you're just playing this solo no one else has
their prediction around it's just a flat 60 bonus damage which is still a ton and very impactful for a
a mythic unique all right i believe that is actually everything wow that is so much new class content new
skills new legendaries new new everything and i didn't even get to talk about some of our other uh
you know more regular class balance changes you know updates to existing skills and legendaries
so make sure you definitely check out the patch notes there is still more changes to come but we're
already really deep into this campfire chat and uh we didn't want to extend it too too much longer so
make sure you check out the passion it's for all the details on those other changes coming as well
yeah thank you so much charles um i know we have gone through a lot of information we're in our 1.5 of
this campfire chat as i said and i mentioned on on social like this is going to be a very beefy
campfire chat we still have two more things that we do want to really cover off uh uh and as charles
had mentioned um there are a lot of other class changes that we didn't actually fit within the
presentation like a lot of balance specific items so that will be on patch notes and patch notes will be
available on our blog for ptr immediately after the stream so please check that out um we are going
to jump into some quality of life items and so uh colin do you want to take us through some quick
quality of life items i'll be coming with 2.0 yeah i'll go quick so we can get to the the super exciting
cool thing um yeah so the first one here is you can now select your preferred town portal location
so how that's going to work is you're going to open up the map and hover over any of the waypoints and
when you right click on it it's going to set that as essentially your preferred location and whenever
you town portal it's going to take you there so this is really helpful for when you're doing whispers
for example you just set the tree of whispers as your preferred location do some whispers when you
press t you go right there you don't have to open up the map then click on the waypoint then click on
accept like it's all very seamless and it's just removing a lot of the inputs that you have to do to
get back to town quickly the next thing here is we're adding a dungeon key inventory tab for things
like nightmare sigils so that just gives you more space for more activities so much room for activities
the next one here is we've done a pretty substantial rework of monster cc and this is in the spirit of
we want to have really clear sort of delineations between normal monsters and elite monsters and we
didn't like how often you're getting slowed down and how mandatory unstoppable could feel um so you
know it always felt bad to be fighting this huge horde of enemies and you see this elite and you're
paying attention to the elite and then like this goat man mauler comes up and like sneak attacks you
and knocks you down for three seconds and that's the thing that kills you that always felt like
bullshit right so what we've done is we've sort of overhauled a lot of the normal monster cc's to be
quick and snappy like you still feel them you kind of want to avoid them still um but they're much less
sort of the reason why you die entirely so the vampire impale when like the the two-hander like
comes and stabs you and stuns you for three seconds that's turned into an immobilize so you can't move
but you can just smack him in the face um and then the werewolf leap is another great example where
previously they'd come out of stealth and like uh leap attack on you and you get dazed and you'd walk
around confused and now they just does it does a quick knockback um this next change here is small but
i think it's a blaster's delight which is all the monsters that had really long death animations
all die instantly you don't have to wait for the loot to hit the ground it's very satisfying you
know the big ass like spider hosts that crawl towards you when you kill them they pop instantly
and all the spiders go and hit the walls and it feels great the zombies feel really good too it like
they pop instantly when you kill them um and it's a very satisfying experience so this should speed up
combat quite a bit and it just feels really good the next thing here is their socketable inventory tab
another tab for you for you to put socketables like gems and other socketables and then there's also an
additional stash tab that we're going to add the next thing if we could roll the clip we took out just
about all the
all would go up and then like click on the plunger and don't get hit by the spikes that's all been
replaced entirely with just monster packs of varying sizes and it's just way more seamless in this case
we only rolled some normal monsters but sometimes it's a couple of elite packs you never really know
what you're going to get it's like an easter or a kinder egg i should say and it just helps the dungeon
flow substantially like to just sort of blast through those things and then a handle full of dungeons have
had their procedural logic updated just so there's more variation in the layout so when you play it
it's just going to roll out differently this is really just iterating on our dungeon set to make
them feel much more sort of flow inducing not slowing you down and then the next one here is is
minor but actually feels uh pretty good and it has a big impact on the game when you get those paragon
and level up notifications we're actually going to tell you how many so sometimes you'll realize oh my
god i have like 15 skill points i can spend um and it actually tells you the number it's a nice quality of
life change so i think that's everything awesome thank you colin for running through quickly i
appreciate the efficiency of of going through all the quality of life changes um now i know uh jivan
has been very quiet over here he's only chimed in a little bit uh and we do want to talk about a new
thing that is coming to vessel of hatred specifically and for vessel of hatred players so jivan will you uh will
you talk us through it a little bit yeah so it's uh it's my privilege to kind of talk about a feature
that the whole team's been working very hard on that we haven't really um mentioned much and you
know we we uh looked at the expansion we had all these cool things you know um torment new class skills
spirit born but we thought there was a hole um and we we wanted to particularly give
build crafters a new way to play for vessel of hatred um this is for folks who like me uh whose dream
cooking show has nothing to do with british baking but instead would be called collins kitchen um push
chat if you would binge collins kitchen let us know um so uh yeah let's and i think some of you already
kind of have an idea um so yeah let's uh let's let's get into uh as some of you already know we're going
to be talking about runewords yeah so um let's let's start with a little background um so runewords were
in diablo 2 and they were a very powerful way of augmenting gear with socketable content and there's a
lot of good sort of nostalgic feelings they were popular they were remembered fondly you can look
on the right that's one of the most iconic um examples from diablo 2 uh the the name is enigma
and you would make it with runes ja if burr and it would get you some some really cool skills that
would come out of it when you put it all together um and for diablo 4 we wanted to retain the soul of
what diablo 2 runewords did which is combining socketable components and creating more powerful
items um but we also wanted to do something that felt appropriately fresh and new and we wanted to
lean into what's unique about the modern game to make the diablo 4 version of runewords and make it
stand on its own and really feel like the right version to be giving to players yeah and what was so
awesome about diablo 2 runewords right was you got the set of runes that made a god item right and
it broke the rules like being able to teleport on other classes like what the hell barbarian is
teleporting across the screen we really wanted to embrace that in a way that extended builds and and
didn't necessarily enforce you must play with this item and we're really excited to share what that's
sort of manifested right yeah and you all have a lot of builds that you you started with from the
base game and we want to add on to those
so what are runewords they're a way for you to make your own spells so there are two types of
runes there's runes of ritual and they specify actions from the player that they have to trigger
so you can see the example here of the yule rune which is a legendary quality rune ritual you have to
cast a skill which has a cooldown so you know frost nova or something like that then you have runes of
invocation and these grant powerful effects as a result of satisfying those runes of ritual so
the example here the gar rune gives you two and a half percent critical strike chance for five
seconds and you can stack up to ten times up to 25 and you can mix and match these there'll be a lot
of different runes of ritual and runes of invocation you can put them together as you see fit
so when you combine a rune of ritual and rune of invocation you pair them together
you put them in an item with two sockets boom you form form a runeword
and as you can tell there's going to be rarity we're going to have magic rare and legendary and
the higher rarity runes will have more potent conditions or effects
so one of the one of the important elements of this is called offering which is the rune resource
system so your runes of ritual will generate offering and they're meant to feed into their
linked runes of invocation so that they can consume that offering and the sort of more demanding
rituals that we would ask of you as a player gain you more offering at the same time the more
powerful invocations that you would try to get require more offering and so there's sort of a sort
of like shared economy there so if you can look at these runes on the right you get 50 offering for
casting a skill with the cooldown and this rune only requires 25 offering for it to trigger that's where
overflow comes in overflow is when an invocation receives an offering in excess of what's needed
to trigger it but put more simply it's we want you to have a mix and match system but we want the
pieces to be um not super hard that they can't fit together easily when they have some rough edges
so many invocations can get different bonus effects when overflowed some of them might get increased
radius to the effect some of them might get increased duration but it'll always be proportional to the
overflow amount so as an example here um the garb rune only requires 25 offering and it's getting
double that which is 50 from the yulb rune so every time you cast this skill with a cooldown you'll
get two stacks of 2.5 critical strike strike chance or 5 crit strike and so that's kind of how you get to
play with this system and you get to optimize it in different ways and it creates a lot of flexibility
right even like if you do a really demanding ritual trigger for example on a really low offering
rune of invocation it's almost a way to start scaling that rune of invocation in a completely
different way beyond just triggering the rune exactly yeah it lets us it lets us as developers
be more flexible in creating wide ranges of effects you know sort of small ones big ones and and also the
same for the rituals and you get to kind of decide which ones you think fit your build or are cool and
we do our best to make sure that you can almost cook up anything
so a few rules um runes can be socketed into items with two sockets um we've added a new another item
to get two sockets for vessel of hatred the uh so you'll have your helm your two-hander your gloves and
sorry your helm two-hander pants and chest um they can only be paired with a rune of the opposite type so you
have to pair a rune of ritual with a rune of invocation you can have a maximum of two runewords
equipped you can't equip the same rune twice and they're available for users who own vessel of hatred
they stack in your inventory in the new socketable inventory tab which will also have your gems
rune of the new socket and runes and runes are tradable between other players who own vessel of hatred
and they unlock with a quest in the campaign both runes dropping from as loot but also runecrafting
which we'll get into later and they drop at a higher rate in the undercity which is a specific
place you can farm them so now let's get into some clips here we get to actually see it in action so this
is a barbarian and the rune of ritual they have is travel five meters very simple and they're going
to join that to the earthquake which is a legendary aspect that you've already seen before which requires
100 offering so you see we'll put them together in this item and then all they have to do is just
run around boom earthquakes dropping insane with the paragon legendary glyph we just talked about
the earthquake train is leaving the station what i love about this is it doesn't it doesn't just count
your normal walking right if you're leaping if you're charging that's all counting towards like
the distance that you're moving right oh whoa and you can see it here in like the whirlwind for instance
like it's obviously spawning earthquakes so was that a druid petrify ultimate that's this is this
must be the wrong clip all right sorry guys you know we're doing it live let's just move on to the next one
um okay so we have a necromancer here with the rune of ritual cast a non-channel core skill getting
25 each and then this is a classic from d2 gain plus three to all skills
um so you'll get to see this necro's got five uh five skill ranks for reap and sever
and they're just gonna go out and casual socketable harlequin crest pretty good
so a little pew pew just doing your basic uh core skill usage filling up the offering needed
yeah i really like the the little tracking buff that like fills up as you as you're getting it so you
don't need to really micromanage this you can just add a glance see that hey i just filled it up and
now i get plus three ranks of sever yep so now you're a plus three there you go what was that so yeah
this this this necro is just cooking and um oh what is this another another broken clip did they just
cast teleport what it what okay i i i think i think you guys 40 necros what are you cooking over there jivan
yeah i'll stop making jokes mostly um yeah so what we really wanted to lean into with d2 runewords
among other things was the ability to cast other classes skills and use their power and harness it
into your build so with runewords you're going to get to do that uh each class is going to share two
skills and one legendary aspect like the uh the earthquake one that you saw um and some of them are
even going to get get to cast improved versions so for instance you know instead of um the standard
decrepify from the necromancer you get to cast horrid decrepify which is the upgraded version
and that's kind of we did that for a lot of reasons you know we wanted to make some of them
feel a little better and a little more powerful and a lot of it is about balance but one important
thing that i always want to um highlight here is that you always cast the best version of the skill if
you have upgrades as the sort of homeowner of the class right so what that means is let's say you're
a spirit born and you equip the cry rune which is the vortex spell if you have points into the upgrade
then you'll cast the upgraded vortex when the rune goes off so i don't think there'll be any class envy
you know like everyone will get the best version of their own skills and then they'll get to use other
classes skills and um we're really excited to see how people can can construct new builds and new
archetypes and and what they can do with using the power of the classes and that says enhanced war
cry so that means necros can become berserk right that indeed does mean that and uh and and that
enhanced war cry is a winner i gotta say that one's real strong we've already seen people just chopping
up the the pit with that one absolutely really looking forward to what kind of interesting new
combinations and builds you can come up with by by dipping into other class skills uh in in unique
ways it really just like multiplies the possibilities of of what you can do with any given class
yeah exactly and not only do we want you to augment your builds with other classes skills but
you know runes will scale with gear so when you get more interesting runes of rituals you'll find ways
to optimize them as well and get more output so we really feel like people will have a lot of theory
crafting that they can build off of the runeword system and i'm very excited to see how you break
the game by the way that's what she do she's doing ptr for me just break break the game see every build
you can find that that totally destroys everything um so now we have the crafting element um so using
three of the same rune you can use them to roll a new rune you go to the jeweler or it might not be the
jeweler but we'll see um and you will combine three of the same exact rune and you'll get a new rune out
that is guaranteed to be different than the rune you put in and there's a chance to uproll it to
the next highest rarity so if you put three magic runes in there's a chance that it'll be a rare rune
same with same with rare there's a chance that it'll be a legendary rune um and then on top of
that we'll have the ability to craft mythic uniques so you can use runes um each route each mythic unique
can be crafted with a specific set of runes you'll need a legendary rare and magic runes of a certain
quantity and one resplendent spark and this is in addition to the existing mythic uni crafting flow
so um yeah i was just gonna say this really harkens back to the sort of crafting that was so core in d2
with the ruins of being able to match three and get the next upgrade but in a way that's a little bit
more flexible and gives you more progression out of it and this is all tradable right so that match
three those crafting mythic uniques what do you think that's going to do with trading yeah i mean
i i think it's going to really build a sort of player community around how to acquire the runes
you need whether it's because you want to combine you know you have two and you want to find that
third one to combine for a new one or you're hunting for a specific mythic unique i think we're
going to have a lot of player interaction and well someone's going to win the capitalism game there so
we'll see how that goes i really like how how the uh the rune crafting system makes it so you're kind
of always progressing right if you're getting room drops then then you're you're you're getting
materials that you know you can use to progress towards higher rarity runes and potentially towards
these mythic unique items unlike uh you know some of the other loot drops you know if you don't find a
good piece of gear it just ends up being salvage here with runes you're kind of constantly getting
some of that progression even if it's not always the perfect room right now yeah i think that's
something that we we did talk to a lot of sort of d2 diehards when we we built runewords and one of the
things that most of them tended to mention consistently was like every rune drop is progress
right you're always moving up that ladder and so we wanted to make sure that even if you didn't get
the exact thing you wanted it still meant something to you one way or another well i know uh we have
we've talked a lot about a lot of stuff today we we had a progression itemization uh we talked about
quality of life we talked about class uh changes and of course the newest thing which is runewords
which will be in vessel of hatred um but the one thing we did want to quickly talk about was ptr
ptr is coming up uh and we want to give a little bit or at least some specifics on what that ptr test is
going to be and also hear from the team on exactly like what they're looking for uh from you guys out
there that are playing like for feedback uh as you guys play through the systems everything that
we've actually talked about today is going to be present in this ptr so uh all the class balance
changes the progression changes uh runewords will also be part of the ptr so we actually do want
players jumping in uh and checking it out so uh let's jump right into some of the ptr items so uh as
everyone knows uh ptr uh from even the last ptr that we had uh will carry over content from your
main account so if you've already done all your renown cleared your fog of war your altar will
stat uh uh status will carry over onto your ptr account uh we did do a character copy as well it was
a while back though so uh there there you may find that it might be a little dated from like the character
copy that you have on live but uh that will exist for players to actually use um one thing i will
note is that we are planning on having two different testing phases for ptr specifically uh the first
testing phase will actually begin next wednesday uh and will run through friday about midday where we're
going to actually give players the opportunity of kind of just starting characters from fresh because we
really need people to try out the new progression systems that uh colin and hazeln were talking about
specifically in the beginning of the stream so wednesday through midday friday we really need players
to jump in check that out give us feedback specifically uh regarding anything tied to the new progression
systems around midday on friday though we will be turning on the rest of the ptr which will include
things like ruin words and and all the other uh features that we were kind of talking about uh
are well all the other features will be part of it but ruin words and things like that will be turning
in on friday one thing that we've heard from feedback from players specifically especially as we have
addressed this in the past is that there is going to be a boost vendor available for this ptr so in
kyovashad players will be able to go and visit this specific vendor this is the best video that i was talking
about because this fallen is dancing and it looks it looks absolutely amazing uh this vendor will be
available and you'll be able to interact with it and this vendor will actually then be able to provide
you a ton of uh enhancements to your character uh which we do have a list of here
uh so you will be able to boost your character up to level 50. level 60 of course which is the new
level cap after vessel of hatred actually ships uh we will end up clearing out your whole map your
waypoints uh fog of war uh we will do your class mechanics stuff and have that already unlocked all
torment tears will be unlocked your potions will be on uh upgraded completely and then i know based
off of feedback that we got from like the last ptr was uh hey it'd be great if we could generate like
legendary items if we can get all the unique items all the runes that are well that's new now but all the
the runes and everything like that including master working materials that will actually be available
in this vendor so this is a way for players to be more efficient while testing and being able to give
us uh more feedback especially around end game related items uh so we really need players to jump in for
ptr one one last caveat i do want to mention is um infernal hordes will not be available in this specific ptr
uh we are still doing some work on that right now uh before we actually get it ready but uh all the
other features within the game will be available infernal hordes as i mentioned will be it's a
permanent feature so it's coming back to the game no matter what uh and then separately um i i do want
to remind everyone that ptr right now it is still just pc battle net only this does give us the flexibility
of being able to upload change things on the fly like things like turning turning runewords on on friday for
instances uh gives us we have the flexibility of being able to do that on on uh our own platform so
it's just easier for us to be able to have that uh additional uh work from our side to to be able to
make things like that happen when we can do testing specifically from that end um but colin aislaine i'd be
really curious to hear like what you guys are looking for specifically in this ptr from feedback from
players uh that they can focus in on and provide feedback on uh as they go into the test
yeah so i think we really want to see people focusing on the new journey so starting from level
one and feeling out what difficulty tier is right for you um and if that feels like it's the difficulty
tier that you would expect to be on based on uh how powerful you've managed to make your character
and how many of the progression systems you've engaged with like if you engage with tempering
and you go all out and you you know like you're like i'm gonna make my character a blaster even
though they're only level 30 like how far can you go with that and are you going as far as you
expected you would be able to go
yeah those are great points it really is about you know are we hitting that expectation that we've sort
of created right which is we really loved how the mine cage was functioning we loved how tormented
bosses felt in terms of having hard mode versions of things um are these difficulty tiers sort of
meeting those expectations of all the things that we have had in the previous game now mapped to a more
streamlined system that should be much much easier to navigate
awesome and i know on the class side like charles what are you kind of looking for what what's the
team looking for on that front yeah i think we're really looking at at the new skills and the new
key passives for each class and and how they're usable at at all points in your character journey
right they should feel good to press when you just first learn these new skills um but they should
also feel really good when you're in the late game and you're trying to you know make you make
a build all around them right around your your stone burst like does it feel like that has
enough support and that you can you know make a stone burst build or or dance of knives and
um or all the other different skills like do they fit in what's their appropriate power level and and
really really want to make sure that the new skills and the new key passives uh enable new ways of
playing our classes and that and they feel satisfying to build that way awesome and jeevan i know you
mentioned to everyone break the game with rune words so wait is there maybe any more extra items
you're looking for in terms of feedback yeah i mean it's definitely mostly about that i want to see
what people come up with i want to see you know what you can cook in terms of build you can do
something fun or cool or unexpected and um also you know i'm highly interested in the sort of balanced
feedback i think we'll get it from all of you but um we've had a lot of people on the team work
very hard on conceptualizing how to make sure this stuff is right on the edge of broken without
actually being broken and you'll get to you'll get to prove me wrong if that isn't the case um yep
awesome well i know um we do want to jump into a little bit of q a before we kind of wrap up i know
we've been here for a little while so we'll try to grab some questions specifically uh from twitch chat
i know uh the probably the most uh popular question right now uh from from the community is about armory and
i do want to start off with that specifically and i do also want to just confirm that we are working
on an armory it is it the team is cooking on it right now uh we just don't have it ready immediately
but as soon as we have an update um we will be providing that uh to the community there is work
for an armory happening we're not purposely ignoring it i promise you uh and it it is in the work
specifically from that end so um i know uh we we have questions from twitch so this is where i
actually like butcher everyone's name so uh in standard fashion i will continue to do that it's
just a little different now because i actually like have a a screen in front of me which is actually
really really beneficial um but i guess we'll start off with a question regarding uh the different
difficulty tiers so this is from double dhz which is uh since we now have eight difficulties does this
mean with power increase in later seasons more difficulties will be added wouldn't uh what are
we planning on adding uh like 20 difficulties like in diablo 3 like what what's the plans around that
yeah we want to be really measured in terms of when we add difficulty tiers
um i think it sets us up for adding them when we feel like it's an appropriate time we don't want
to get to a spot where we have 20 different difficulty tiers we want to have just enough
granularity to support the amount of power that we're adding and what we don't want to do is sort
of say okay we're going to add things like runewords or add things like seasonal powers and then nerf all
of you by making the monsters 100 tankier to compensate for the power we'd actually rather create a system
that when you get that new power we're going to add another band of difficulty to get even more
efficiency out of that power and so that's been the sort of guiding light is we don't want to
continue to sort of nerf players into a spot where they can sort of use all this new power to push
a great example of that is previously in seasons we would actually increase monster health to
compensate for some of the seasonal powers now if you get seasonal powers if you're blasting penitent
and leveling to 60 faster good for you like that's something that we think is actually
really important to the system
awesome um i know next question that we have this is a question i've seen a a decent amount
this is from explosive cat hopefully your cat is not exploding uh what's the purpose of nightmare
dungeons now that glyphs have moved out of pit yeah so nightmare dungeons are going to be where
you receive your master working materials um and because nightmare dungeons are going to be following
the difficulty tier uh system now you're going to be able to go into higher torment tiers or rather higher
difficulty tier uh nightmare dungeons and get more uh master materials out of that so just like you know all
other kinds of content in the game now being able to go into a higher difficulty of that activity is
going to ultimately be better for you yeah the grind sort of putting a grind currency actually fits much
better in a nightmare dungeon compared to the pit because it means that every sort of elite you kill
every chest you open or every corner you go into and you find an elite pack those are going to be
master working materials as opposed to today where it's like well the instant i make a turn that is not in the
in the direction of finishing this dungeon has been a waste of my time because i want that cliff that
can play completely changes when everything in the dungeon is dropping master working materials and we
think that feels so much better for that type of content um conversely you know with the pit uh you
know again we're going to reward you for pushing difficulty and we do want you to sort of get there
quickly and get that reward and get out so we think that'll feel a lot better yeah so just just for
people because i think when they immediately heard like well now it's just moved to nightmare dungeons and
it's just at the end it's actually part of of the the the the whole nightmare dungeon it's not
just the end goal getting to the end and do and getting you know master working materials there just
want to clarify for chat because i know immediately there's a good amount there's a good amount at the
end when you kill the boss right of course the boss has to have good but like what's really
going to feel great is like when you run into a massive elite pack like you just randomly run into you know we
spawned maybe too many those are all going to represent you know little loot bags of master
working materials which is going to be huge awesome um this question is from rxc 105 um are runes reusable
um yeah so um well i just want to say chat i've been reading i've been reading twitch chat and what
you've said has uh struck a chord anyway um yes they will be re-even can't take you anywhere um you
could unsocket runes and you can uh move them into different items yes absolutely um i saw a few related
questions to that uh they they don't get to exist in the same um item as gems you do have to pick between
gems and uh runes on any individual item awesome um i know there was a question related to um
another well at least oh i don't know i don't know charles you want to answer this or if you have
additional details there's a lot of questions related to one of the mythic uniques and it's uh
additive damage to demons and angels specifically um i don't know if you want to talk about i will
confirm that is the wording on the effect plus damage to angels and demons there you go guys
we'll just leave it at that um and no further i know yeah no further comment on that um additional
question that we have related to uh paragon is why cap the amount of boards and instead of just
capping maybe the amount of lifts we can use this is from hotner yeah that's a really good point um
something that i think we can take back and really think about we had discussed and we felt like the
cleanest solution from just sort of the um flow perspective was that we wanted to just make it really
sort of compact and make those choices about which glyphs and which legendary nodes and eventually
what rare and magic nodes matter to you but that's really good feedback and something we can continue
to monitor as we go into ptr and as people get their hands on it again it's really about making
those boards more punchy and the connections between those boards is something that you navigate
during your journey but the sort of end point is about making those really chunky choices on what
glyphs you want and what legendary nodes you want um and we think that ultimately especially now that
paragon is realm wide and all your alts i think we touched on that earlier all your alts get to
benefit from this um it's really going to streamline that process of getting your points locked in
quickly on those alt characters and get them into the end game really quickly um so but that's a really good
point of feedback um a question from
um
wtf akalaka
i see this is this is bad yeah you get the point well everyone need to be in kyobashad to change
difficulty like it is currently
that's a good question we've added actually yeah so um you could imagine how obnoxious it would be to
do the pit in karagar and then have to go to kyobashad to then unlock the new torment
tier that you just got so we actually added um difficulty tier selectors in karagar as well as
kyobashad in addition to kyobashad and then we also have one in krast and there's also another one
i think near the dark citadel entrance we've added them in a few locations across the game just to make
that a little bit of a better experience
a question from a few people there's like corintern there's another question from nine tons of pain
uh are lists kind of shared between all characters in the realm or do they have to be leveled up
separately
um so those are still leveled up separately but that's something like going forward we definitely
want an emphasis on like making alts more seamless to play into and we definitely um there's some
underlying feedback there which is wouldn't it be great if the paragon lists for account wide and it's
like yeah that's something we can take back to the team and philosophically um you know we really
want to start moving towards a direction where making alts is really easy to get into and feel
powerful um so that's something we can definitely take note of and i'll also highlight that right
the because the paragon points are shared account wide or um realm wide as it were um if you make
a new character you're going to get a ton of paragon points right away which increases your player
power level which may be means you take on a higher pit tier and then you get the catch-up mechanic
on leveling up those glifts so it is a little bit easier for your alts to level up those glifts as well
even if it's not 100 shared yeah that's very true you can level up you can level them up really fast
in the pit if you're pushing deep um there is a question regarding eternal realm characters like
what happens to them when 2.0 kind of launches what's the like do i'm assuming because they already
have like 925 gear if they're at max level they'll be brought down to that to that uh new eye level that we
had mentioned is there like any specific changes or anything or is it kind of laid out exactly kind
of how we presented oh i can answer this uh yeah yeah um so uh we are doing some adjustments to for
those eternal players who really like to play the game on one character we wanted to make sure that
there was new loot to chase we also just needed to make sure that with the new character level
adjustments um you know we sort of had to adjust the eye power of items now that the fact that the
max character level is 60 in addition to our goals of really sort of creating more grounded numbers
it does mean level 50 is getting an eye power adjustment as well as the affixes are being adjusted
but we are going to max roll every single affix that we adjusted power wise so for example if you get a
five we're going to take those items and adjust them uh we aren't going to re-roll those affix bands
like if you had perfect affixes um we're just going to essentially max roll all of them within that
band so there's no feels bad about you know i had this perfect item and you ruined it by readjusting it
but the sort of main takeaway there is we wanted to make sure in patch 2.0 that there was new loot to
chase um you know we wanted to make sure that the new uniques had a place to sing um and that that's
all sort of in service to that for that type of eternal player who really likes that sort of long
form progression awesome uh question from ice pantha rumors are they applicable to all items and
weapons are they restricted to specific types of equipment um additionally can gems be inserted into
equipment with runes yeah um there they can be inserted into all types of equipment so they're not
restricted from being in uniques as long as you know you have two sockets for that unique and the the
to restate the um the slots that are available with two sockets you used it in on base game it's three
it's uh chess pants and two-hander we're also adding a second socket to helm so you'll have four slots
um and you cannot mix runes with gems in any item and you wouldn't want to you'd basically be losing the
benefit of them awesome um i know we have some questions related to like some co-op bugs i i will
say that um i've gone on i know like forums and reddit and addressed uh at least address them that we are
working on them i can tell you the team is most definitely working on them right now excuse me as i call
still getting over my my sickness uh uh and then i know uh this is actually a pretty i'm gonna ask this
because it's a funny question are there runes for g and then bun oh i mean my narcissism certainly
would have let me do that but i i think i think we can't uh we can't we can't do that sort of stuff
unfortunately i would love to but i will say um there are you know the the runes have these sort of
phrases that they unlock when you actually compose the spells and we have some i think fun references and
easter eggs to you know the great diablo games of the past and um so hopefully that'll kind of
make you smile when you see them awesome and then uh runes are they stackable
yeah they are stackable and we we have added a new tab for them as well we have a socketable tab
so the runes all your runes and gems will go there um so there we go you know would be pretty good for
your inventory yeah that it that would have been really messing with inventory if if runes did not
stack and now that they have yeah and now they have their own tab which is really really good so
um cool i know uh we are going we are very over on time um so i do wanna i do wanna make sure that we
um let everyone go here so that they can eat because we've now gone well past lunch over here in
california um just a reminder for everyone that ptr is actually going to be starting next wednesday
we will have patch notes and the blog up immediately after the stream specifically here so you guys can
check it out check out the patch notes it's 17 000 words a lot of words so i apologize um i will say
that for other locales it might be until like early next week before those patch notes will be available
it just takes a while for us to localize on some of those and it kind of came in a little hot so
we do plan on actually having that available in all languages just for now they will be english only and
immediately up after this specific stream again ptr starts next wednesday we'll have two different
phases wednesday through friday will be that first initial phase where we need players jumping in
checking out the progression changes and testing all that out and then starting on friday for the
uh the the rest of the week specifically uh we'll end up having uh the boost vendor available where
players can actually jump in and uh you know test out everything that they need to uh regarding runewords
and all other things that are tied to endgame um i do want to give a huge uh thanks to everyone on
this panel here colin aislaine charles jeevin thank you so much for going through a ton of information
um i do want to also call out the rest of the diablo team because they uh have been doing a ton of work
towards uh vessel of hatred and of course patch 2 2.0 and season six one thing we will say is that
you guys actually haven't heard about season six yet we still have information to tell you about season
six we'll be uh sharing that more here in the coming weeks as we head towards launch so there is still
uh a seasonal uh theme and mechanic with season six that we'll be uh sharing here soon so thank you
guys everyone and thank you diablo community for tuning in check out diablo4.com immediately after
the stream and uh we'll see you guys in sanctuary thanks again thanks everyone oh we're ending with
this best i love it we can't forget the most important member of the team
so
uh
Good night.
Oh, my God.
Thank you.